hello welcome back to my Python
tutorials in the last tutorial we were
talking about how to delete files and
directories in this tutorial I want to
be showing you guys how to do something
a little less destructive and this time
we're just going to be renaming and
moving files about and actually this
process is the same for whether you want
to rename remove a file so anyway let's
go ahead and get right on into it I've
made an example oh I have not made an
example file so I'm going to go ahead
and make an example text file and I'm
just going to call it rename me and then
we're also going to ren name me we're
also going to have just create a sample
folder for when we go to move the files
so now how do we do this so we're going
to look at rename me and we're going to
need a import OS and this is a one-liner
as well that we could just throw in here
though since we have two variables it's
good to go maybe define them beforehand
but you don't have to so for example we
could just say OS rename this is the
renaming function and in here you have
two variables you have a previous name
and a new name and this is kind of why I
think that sometimes it's helpful to use
variables because you might get these
two things flipped so because your
previous name in your new name is highly
likely to be somewhat similar and so
it's it's helpful to have variables to
define this so I'm gonna go ahead and
define some variables and that's going
to be equal the first variable is going
to be Wren
name me dot txt that's our first file
now the new file so the new name is
going to be equal to we'll just say it
names text just so we can see it and
then in here we'll just put pre name and
new name we'll save that and let me just
push this down a little bit so when we
go to run and sure enough you can see if
the files now been
to name and nothing is really spit out
okay so the next thing is okay what if
we want to move the file you said it's
the same thing
what is the same thing so you could say
the previous name is name text the new
name is sample folder slash name text so
now we'll save that let's run that and
you see you know everything's the same
here and then in sample folder we look
in here now there's name and you could
you could have moved it and named it
anything else that you wanted so the
next question before I let you all go is
what if we take that's the previous name
and what if we rename this to die CSV
and we run that sure enough you can see
the file name has even been changed as
well so I mean you can change everything
about the file now so in previous
tutorials I've showed you guys how to
append files write files read from files
now you know how to delete files
directories rename directories rename
files and move files and then you can
use this as well to move directories so
hopefully that's been pretty helpful for
you guys hopefully you enjoyed as always
thanks for watching and stay tuned to
more videos